for the raffle commission as attractive
parra santonja low clock landed me
you can on the tube in council in the
credits intention to contribute want to use
the two-state solution we
want a democratic, peaceful
israel and we want an independent
palestine that is also recognized by israel and
europe  will victoria become a daughter
youtube now there is light at the
end of the tunnel
the countries have returned to a course of
growth the
crucial question now is what are
the countries italy and france doing
once their identity has saved money
striesow's comedian cia in europe
that has been bothering me ever since  version of opposition circles
he first left social and treatment
please not in a fresh way
as the united states of
america will be the bigger culprit on this earth
we also have to see that this
consequence of acts of terrorism
at babbel public emanates from
a swiss film and the result